are you cuckoo for cocoa puffs they are
all right but they do scratch the top of
my mouth
yeah i'm like that way with bagels like
you ever been eating a bagel it's like
the food is like stuck in your mouth and
i love the cream sorry
no not the cream cheese the bagel part
but you know what i don't like is when
eating a bag when the cream cheese like
splurts out of the middle and then i get
to the section where it's
just cream cheese and i have to kind of
just like disperse the cream cheese like
i have to like i'll take like a little
bit of cream cheese and then
a little bit of the outside of the bagel
just to like kind of even it out
no you're one of those people i wrote
down
i wrote down there's two types of people
in the world the type of person who
makes sure that their food is eaten in
an even way yeah
and then the type of person who orders
more just asks for more chips instead of
making sure all the chips fit with the
guava are there people like that yes
there's people that are like can we just
ask for more chips it's not a big deal
don't worry about it there are people
that mix all their food
to begin with and then people who mix it
then eat it they mix it they need it
like when they have like curry
on rice i like all of it together but
when you're with white people you have
to
perfect amount of ratio it's like that
dimitri martin joke where he's like
every time you eat a salad you make a
mini salad on your fork you know a
little bit of tomato a little bit of
onion
a little bit of lettuce like i said i
okay jesus christ i'm sorry dude
i'm twisting the mic around so that it
[ __ ]
stays on it's really trippy when i take
this off
that's when chrissy was supposed to talk
what was i loud am i loud now
uh i can't wait okay sorry i think i'm
like
yeah you're proud to be loud
this makes it a lot easier having a
headphone like as far as like a solo
podcast
because it just sounds better and yeah
because we're funny
so uh i want to ask hans if
is when you have a thing of guacamole
and a thing of chips
do you like worry a lot about making
sure that
the chips and guacamole run out at the
same time
yes really okay because a lot of people
are like no
relax like it doesn't need to
it'll be fine no i i hit it it's like my
biggest pet peeve when i'm like when i
just have a little bit of guacamole left
i'm like [ __ ]
no more chips like this is a disaster
yes
and uh i also like mixing foods with
like other foods like if i have like a
plate with like a lot of things on it
i'll just like
eat i'll just like i'll just kind of
like just just like eat some macaroni
like kale like potatoes chicken just
like kind of just like
like spoon it into my mouth like really
fast so i get
so i get that flavor you know it's just
like like
and what are you talking about so you're
trying
everything on your body i'm trying to
eat it all that well like
i'm trying to mix the flavors and then i
just eat it really fast so i'm trying to
like mix the flavors i'm like okay so
i'm like get a mix of macaroni with
mashed potatoes and then mashed potatoes
are still in my mouth so i'm going to
mix that and then
this is this
no not when i'm on a date just when you
know when i really that's like that's
the most enjoyable sound
worse without the headphones on
okay it's like asmr with the headphones
on
hey what's up guys this is going to be
an easier way to do this
this thing doesn't spin out two
microphones well hans doesn't have any
homo boundaries so he'll be fine
yeah but christy has a lot of hang ups
and she's proud of them we're raised
i don't know if you know how old i am
but i was raised to 32
no 14 41 39 i was raised to be very
ashamed of
uh what called yourself
yeah as soon as i got with my first guy
everyone was like
oh she's the biggest more tell me more
tell me more you were nine because you
[ __ ]
a 40 year old yeah so
as you were in it you're from somewhere
person gang bang
you're from somewhere where they just
like steal girls
and tie them up and run lines korea is a
very civilized place
my area like where i'm from girls like
are
valued a lot and they go to a husband
and cows that are used for breeding
what are you guys used for for their
humanity
empathy and y'all dress yours up like
children the whole time
are women yeah that's because that's why
they're hot
yeah that's because they're the second
best to children we'd
obviously rather have children but you
know women are this next thing
dude women are like children we
we sure do try to act like it around you
guys uh yeah because
i don't do you what do you mean i used
to yeah
sugar baby the whole thing because you
want money
yeah i had a higher voice like three
years ago can you do an
impression it's really hard i was
thinking about this today like
whenever you stop faking something
and then you start again do it if you do
it i'll do it
dude you don't you didn't like my
impression of like a
twink that's trying to appease his gay
lord
oh my god i'm scared if i do it you have
to do it no because i don't know i don't
remember how to get back oh my god
that is such a funny story oh my god
oh do you guys do you just want to put
your
[ __ ] in me right now oh
yo do you know who uh
no that's a twink that's uh do you know
who um
whatever you do you know a guy named
otter
it's a like a person named otter in new
york yeah a human being that we're gonna
talk about
no i'm just saying dude first of all the
most funny i love
otter he's a funny gentleman person i
don't know if it's
it's a funny person and uh sounds like
that you know
but uh yes
um mine you just like really act like a
baby as much as you possibly can
you know you just act like yeah like you
envision like a toddler who's like that
cute girl with a little dress on and she
like has a little pigtails
you have a lollipop yeah and are we
gonna go to e
like uh i don't yeah i don't really find
that that attractive
i don't know i don't trust well oops uh
the girl that you
one of the people that you said that
you've recently [ __ ]
seems to have that aesthetic um
aesthetic aesthetic she has
like she has a little uh well you were
just saying most girls do did she do
that
um in bed at all like a baby thing but
you don't
i guess not um
she did it she did a baby thing
uh yeah i changed her diaper
oh i don't know uh yeah she
had a pacifier and um there's certain
races and stuff like
black women will not do the baby thing
they're like
this is how it is this is real life but
in bed they do it a lot
do they yeah okay excuse me i had no
idea
wait did they do the baby thing they
like i started acting like
whoa because they're just so tired of
being so big and black
um
wow i didn't know yeah you have to you
have to see somebody in that light
to really know you never know what
they're going to be like
you know if you fight if the dog with
the biggest spark
has the whatever i just think that uh
love
i just think that love is childlike and
you know it makes sense that
you would act like a child around i mean
men do that too
like i like this one guy did baby voice
to me bro
that's what dude that's what people do
it's like insane
that's what people do when they like
someone because like love is like
the most like thing it's like the most
innocent because it's stupid as [ __ ]
it's like it's innocent
it's like it's like you're reverting
back into like you know
a child that's why children are the best
at sex
they're genuine they're like this is
actually how i feel right now
with this yes uh traumatized
they're genuine i'm glad derek isn't
here for this right why would you say
that
i don't you're gonna summon him um sorry
i'm talking about my friend yeah i mean
what do you think about
the whole crew in austin and how we're
doing it
we're doing it live have you all been
having a good few days
yeah we've been having a great few days
i've been having a blast
you've been like yeah yeah yeah you quit
comedy and started being what are you
talking about i did comedy last night
i did comedy the other night the night
before
he has a good schedule he gets up at six
or something
yeah but how was the kimchi mike i
didn't go
is kim terrific sorry it's spicy yeah
you're too busy climbing on cop cars
being miley cyrus without a permit um
it was a little wayne song last night
ended up being cool you know
they're funny the band people the vulcan
bands
yeah another hour they're funny they're
great guys
and they're very musicians um
you know i got drunk i guess so that's
all
and then okay that's all oh
okay so you said that um why
um i subscribed to a girl on only fans
because who yourself
that's so narcissistic you would be
you're like your only subscriber
to yourself um whoa
you're twiddling i saw porn in yourself
with you
really sure you're into pornography yeah
you saw porn with me
i saw it pouring up oh okay
um this girl like she like lays out her
whole heart
on tick tock as like a wholesome being
and then all of a sudden she's like
i have an only fans and i have fun on it
oh wow that's so hot
so like you have a lot of curiosity
because you you know people
you you can't imagine what they what
it's like everyone has sex
you see it because you're someone you
actually know
what what if every
girl had an only fans and you're like i
want to subscribe
to blank players so that's what happens
is like especially the more wholesome
the girl is
in your life and like the more cool you
just see a girl in the park you're like
damn that girl's fine and she has like a
booty you walk out your shorts
you're like hey can i get your only fans
that's that's a possibility so yeah this
girl
at first when i looked at it it was 200
to subscribe and i was like
that's a pretty good deal but i looked
at it yesterday it was 20
so i spent my last 20 i told you i ran
out of money
i spent my last 20 on it and i looked
through all her stuff
why are you jealous of her
yeah no why would you do it then
because she has no self-control impulse
control
i needed to see i needed to know
what it what was going on she seeks
hedonistic pleasure at everything
it's perfect marketing by this girl like
i see you turn it down too much
she's like uh yeah
uh she's like we're having i'm having so
much fun apartment
um this is my apartment this is where i
film my work videos
and you're like what the [ __ ] is going
on so
was it fun was it um it's [ __ ]
i don't like it
i can show you i can show you her latest
video it's like she starts off shy as
[ __ ] like never shows anything and then
like recently
she just like goes goes for it and her
latest video guys
from yesterday is what did you say why
don't you just show us
we'll rate it should i show you now or
is it a good time
i'm just going to go to it and you can
talk about whatever you want to talk
about
i mean it's really hard to make porn uh
i someone has a joke where they're like
only fans is like porn
if girls made porn it's the worst
thing but what do you do that's so true
they don't know what we're into they
know what they want to show
oh are you saying that you don't think
it looks good they do know what we're
answering
some girls are great at it some girls
are awful at it and that's why i get
cringe tick tock and cringe only fans
yeah that's true oh my god i don't know
what you're talking
well how many only fans things have you
seen this is my first time yesterday
i haven't seen any i've seen like
advertising you're so interested
it's not that good like at all it's not
yeah i know it's not
it's really um bad it's like if uh
antelope had to make hunting it's like
if someone was an idiot and actually
paid for porn
yeah you know the stupidest audience
even if i'm
the why would i she makes so much money
from it though so like a thing has
um 380 likes on it so that's 380 times
20 dollars a month yeah so you should do
it
that's a lawyer salary dude and she's
learning
dude i need to start because like is
this her actual account who is that god
i
i got all ner i showed a bunch of people
yesterday and i got all nervous so this
is her i know that girl this is like
what you
get if you pay for it um yeah i paid the
20 thing
oh it's like instagram where you can
like it sagalicious
uh there's a video but um
it's cool because if you know her and
you're like damn she's
if you know her like if you know the
person the exposure but then
i mean then that would just make that
would just be like oh i'm just getting
to know her behind the screen
and that's almost like why you guys want
to have sex with a girl what was your
name
what'd you say that's their username on
i didn't i'm not going to
that's almost like part of why y'all
would want to have sex with a girl
is because not only just that you want
to have sex with her but
you want to see that other side of her
uh
what do you mean i want to see because
she's acting a certain way she's like
act has this certain personality but if
you can squeeze in somehow and get to
see that other side of her
you're going to see that other [ __ ]
side of her and it's like weird
yeah but why not see that's a really
crazy video and what she does a lot
is she has a dildo in her and
she is actively tasting herself
over and over again um
it's cool because it's her own
self-expression and if you vibe with
that
then it's awesome because she doesn't
have to change anything about her it's
like an art
and you don't have to change anything
about yourself do you think that
together
do you think that she really wanted to
taste herself or she just was like
seeking for sinking variety of the video
a little bit of both
because you know and yeah
uh do you want to taste yourself she
posts like three times a day
talking about what i was far away can
you turn it up a little
whatever we don't have to talk about
this yeah why what's going on
uh that's like all right that's good i
think i mean how do you what are y'all's
opinions on
this kind of stuff like i think it's
only fantastic something that people do
and i don't care
i think any sexuality displayed in a
sick society is gonna be sick
and this is not that bad i mean it's a
lot of power
but it's good that people are having
avenues of expressing their sexuality
free from any
gatekeepers yeah and it's good to that
people can express themselves and
communicate sexually
and more sexual communication the better
yeah the closer we come as a species
and uh like do you know who tana monica
is or whatever uh do you no
she's just like like this big basically
huge youtube personality person and
everything but she's like a
huge [ __ ] and she went from being like
she's a 10 now she's like done all this
stuff to herself which is great like
she's
whatever okay but the only reason she's
not
fully said it just costs her 10 000
the only reason she's not fully a [ __ ]
is because like you know the platforms
don't even allow that
yeah so then so she has a only fans and
her bio
says this is where i can express myself
freely
my naked self freely um i think that's
pretty dope
yeah i subscribed it was free
it was free but um the bad stuff like
there's levels and stuff you start you
have to pay for the bad stuff
the um the goods the more free stuff
the more freedom you have to pay for
that
yeah um
so yeah i think that's pretty cool i
mean yeah
hey but she was so this the
ugly one um was making at least five
was making at least 5 000 a month before
for like a few months she wasn't even
getting naked
or doing anything and she was making at
least 5 000 a month
and so that's why i was like i might do
a bikini just like bikini [ __ ]
i mean hopefully we can value people for
something more than just their raw
sexuality
i mean i'm a i'm a prospect of people
than
just little genitals he makes juice
i may you make jews too that's
i think that's bad fans why
okay i thought you were talking about
semen yeah
i was talking about he started making
history
yeah i don't know if you should say why
because
i mean yeah you're selling your body for
juice
is that just this girl is selling her
body
for a sexual appeasement but you can't
just have a society that just makes sex
videos for each other we're paying you
we are paying you for what what for just
signing up or whatever like
what are you paying my tax dollars i
paid thirty dollars in taxes
you're a man can you like think
you don't get any of that money huh what
are you talking about hans he gets
unemployment
oh yeah oh you're making a thing about
unemployment
yeah you're just like oh you have to
sell your body you have to sell your
body and it's like just making a point
about what you were talking about
i'm allowed to take unemployment that's
what it's for this is how a functioning
society did you sign me up because
by being animal and having pride yeah
but
could you sign me up for because i don't
know i would be happy to live in the
wild
if i had to but i have to live in a
society where i can't just hunt
you don't have to yes i do where can i
go
where i have to do where i can live oh
you mean the woods that you have to pay
for and you have to move every two weeks
and that's mapped out by everyone
and also a society that hasn't taught me
any of the skills i need to survive in
the wild
why did you say you have to move
everything dude go to northern canada
i don't want to live in the winter i
don't have to live in the winter just to
escape from you
i should be able to totally afford me
unemployment is your right communism is
within your reach
we can have it right now this isn't a
hitler rally but maybe [ __ ] you
trying to unemployment shame me just
because i'm like
you try you're selling your body for
juice you're selling your body for
sexual pleasure and you can't have a
society where you're just making sex
videos for each other
there's more to humanity than just like
[ __ ] each other
there has to be more that's like empty
goal yeah what is it
what are we gonna do though space travel
no what if that's nerd [ __ ] dude
yeah yeah that's the future of ours i
wanna scuba dive
um for shipwrecks but not to tr hunt for
treasure just
like chill random why what else are we
gonna do
uh not do that because it's a waste of
time i don't wanna space travel
the [ __ ] well you don't have to build
robots that do it for you
dude how do you guys feel about the
building that fell down in miami
what building do you guys know about
that no it was like a limestone thing
like it was like a foundation like a
gateway which is like hard to test for
you know like the ground could just go
on out from under you and there's
it doesn't matter how good you build
that building it's still gonna fall down
it's like one of those things that
happened but if it was like
architectural error i don't think it was
though because i don't know if they know
that yeah collapse do they know that yet
do they know what happened
i don't think so i didn't see anything
about it yeah but i used to be so
scared in new york when i would like
envision how many
things were above me when i was just
sleeping trying to go to sleep
like how many beds and pieces of
furniture and [ __ ] would fall on you
yeah in new york that's not natural yeah
i know
that's not natural to be underneath that
all of that but i mean monkeys sleep on
top of each other
like different like hammocks yeah
pretend you're a tree
they have hammocks no they don't have
yes they do and they eat bananas
they have hammers and they're hammocks
well how do they make the hammers and
they listen to monkey music where it's
like
ooh banana i think they're in like vodka
yeah you need to find a comedian that
matches your like a
thing so that y'all can both like work
off of each other
and in these things okay you know what i
mean it's supposed to be you
you're supposed to be bouncing off of
yeah yeah but you and i are so realistic
he's like
he's like talking about dancing monkeys
on hammocks that's the real
thing what are you talking about that's
what they do but if you found somebody
if somebody came
that's what they do and they play
saxophones yeah if somebody came
what's wrong with you who like could
match you y'all would be really silly
you know you'd have like a silly thing
yeah well maybe who do you think would
be the best person for riley to do maybe
a baby crystalia like mikey biggs
they would just go off on tangents i
don't know who that is
mikey jack timmons
yeah let's get him in here let's call
our men hey guys
and what about if they also have a flute
yeah dude and do and like they wear
shoes right it's so
easy to just make fun of someone but why
don't you do a joke why don't you do a
joke
it's so easy to just like make fun of
someone just analyze
me right now analyze me
uh tell us what's wrong with riley just
as
and to the court to the new segment
what's wrong with ryan
what's wrong with riley dude
uh i was watching the rescue crew
at the uh building i don't like this
story
i mean wrong i was watching tv that's
how the story is
the rescue crew at the building they're
working against time and it's like 30
rescue guys
under underwater in the basement like
trying to drill out
only one guy is working and the rest are
standing around watching
they're they don't want to work really
not an allegory for life
they're not running around like trying
to like trying for patterns
there's 150 missing people where are
they
do they have more more drills like they
probably do
the mayor is there going like they're
working as fast as they can and the
video just shows all of them like
watching one guy drill doesn't mean that
they're not working hard
uh none of the views expressed by
christy are shared by
anyone else on the podcast who's chris
i just think that like if 150 people are
like under the rubble you
you should be like at least looking like
you're taking some results
at the theater of you should be at least
like if i was over there in a suit in a
vest i would be like lifting a piece of
rubble no i can't pull it up i don't
know how
because if everyone is looking for it
there's more chance of cavins
so you think that they should just stand
there
i think you should do a scientific
approach that isn't going to appease
people
like you who are just taking glimpses at
it
if you were stuck under rubble you'd be
so pissed yelling you'd be like
get the [ __ ] over you you lazy [ __ ] like
that's what you would be doing
if your leg was stuck under a rubber you
like look like you're working
yeah a piece of material like
a piece of material you know you went
through 911 and you don't know what
rubble is were you here during 9 11.
i was in northern canada at the time
okay it was santa claus
uh i was on vacation
what's rubble that's like the definition
of white privilege what's rebel
like everyone's like yeah rebel i
thought you were saying rebel and then
when red bull red bull makes you gives
you wings
yeah red bull sponsor us
um what about you guys
uh i don't know what what what do you
mean what about us
um i just i have another topic but if
you guys want to bring one up
um what's your topic let's not do topics
okay
let's do the topical portion and then
after that we're doing the tropical
portion
which is when we all put on grass straw
hats and
drink pina coladas hey welcome to the
tropics
it's like we're kind of drunk and it's
like you know we did the whole day and
now we do a podcast
you know what are you talking about i
tried to do a podcast with y'all
at 1am last night i don't remember that
i know it's okay i wasn't i was asleep
yeah i got in and out last night do you
think that that's a good idea
do a podcast later at night yes
especially when it's not at 2 a.m or 3
a.m in the morning
yeah and i was texting you i said we i
want to do
2.5 hours of podcast kind of podcasting
a day
and you didn't reply oh
i don't know what to say to that next
question
do you think it's stupid to to try to do
that
let's do a blind date all right you guys
go on a date
i'll i'll judge you uh hey nice to meet
you
i just want to know if you think it's
stupid to try to do it to try to do that
breaking the fourth wall
it's not stupid go on a date now go oh
hey
so um do you like wearing gloves and
stuff
when i'm driving okay what's your name i
hate yo i hate it people ask me
my name at the beginning of
conversations that wasn't the same
what does it have to do with anything
yeah i know i don't like it too but it's
it's kind of like just a way to like
acknowledge each other yes
yes yes yes yes no it's a stupid thing
to do it's you
are dumb if you do that no it's not
it's not it's i've been so rude to
people tonight it is dumb no it's not
it's a way of looking someone in the
eyes and being like hey
hey it's a pleasure to meet you i ask
you your name i give you a reason
because i think there needs to be a
reason
so i'll ask you no not what's your name
but like hey my name is riley nice to
meet you
that's a good thing to do um it's so
it's
here's the thing here's the thing we
meet so many people
and in our industry there's a lot of
pressure to remember names so when i'm
overwhelmed in a corner and you come up
to me and throw your name at me are you
in a corner
i'm waiting at something you come up to
me and you go hey remember
hey remember this riley okay bye
and then now next time you come up to me
you're like you remember
do you remember like a month later and
i'm like no
no no one's pressuring you to remember
yes they are
no no they're not usually they do it if
you have a connection
but yeah you need a connection
especially if you're entering a
conversation
a lot of uh people
are like you they want to get under your
skin and into your brain so they can
convince you to [ __ ] them
so yeah a lot more [ __ ]
in social conversations with so that i'm
like
i'm i'm freaking out and they're like
calm down come to my bed
yeah yeah don't be weird take off your
clothes i'm having an identity crisis
because of all the toxic things you said
to me
do you feel that a lot what are you
talking about i have a way with women
um you're a little woman like uh
there you go right on hand
i bet you eat people's asses
no i was doing an impression of you with
the guitar and the moth
like come here a little bit oh there's a
moth i got stuck in the guitar but
luckily i showed my face and it was
light enough
i went towards the light
that's so funny and a good joke uh thank
you do you really think so
yeah i like that you should you should
actually say that on stage
it's not i said i can't go i can't go
out at night because moths ain't got my
light
yes i love it an all-white
light i'm a light to white people
the white light if i if i rest my hair
give it up for riley the white light
if i rest my arm near fat women in the
south
sometimes they try to eat it because
it's it looks like caramel
is that funny no no yeah chicken wing oh
yeah
they're like look at that all right yeah
it looks like a
oh turkey went okay dark
oh who left this turkey leg uh oh yeah
i'm gonna just kind of bite into it on
the bus i think fat people are
their worst dude though all the [ __ ]
what about tyler brown no i'm just
joking
um you can't do that no i think fat
people who
only like food are the worst that's
literally a trap you like open up a safe
haven for me to like say something and
then you shut it and you're like
no well this is well i'm just saying my
opinion you can say your opinion
but you said it you opened it up and
made it really safe for me to say that
what that i agreed and then you're like
when there's like pressure behind it
to not
um laugh at their faces there's pressure
to not um
show that you notice or whatever oh like
a normal
400 pound person i think most people
like that
i don't know yeah you're right i don't
know i had a friend in high school who
was like
getting fat and stuff and i like was so
mad about
i was like but i didn't see not if she's
like that fat if she's huge
like yeah like obviously you acknowledge
it but if she was just like a little fat
then like
don't be like hey you're kind of fat
it's it's a pro
remember in high school i don't it's a
problem for girls because
when you want to hang out with guys they
go hey bring your hottest girlfriends
they always say that
so you need hot you need hot dogs
so you're like oh i would always have
like i would be like oh [ __ ]
what girls are like actually hot enough
and so and
you want them to you want to like them
so i want to make out with most
when your favorite people are ugly
you're like could you get yourself
to be hot fit yeah and ready to
just be successful to be successful they
got to be good at dancing
dude what if you guys were a bunch of
slobs you know what i mean
it's like what are we doing have you
seen riley
yeah your slabs but at least like you're
still not
fully collapsed into that you know what
the [ __ ]
you can always turn it around
no i don't know it's fine i'm pretty
clean okay
clean man and you're just uh sorry
putting your unrealistic standards of uh
beauty make sure to have a mint on me
dude remember
when we become successful we're all
gonna look like tony hinchcliffe
right we already do perfect in a cool
costume every single day
but he did that just sounds like a
positive when you got
promoted when you got promoted he had a
purple glove like a marionette he had a
purpose he was dressed like the joker
yeah oh really yeah i saw him last night
and it's like
he's a cartoon character yeah he's like
on purpose plays with his form
i love him do that now do it i love it
that's so amazing
and he keeps everything shiny and clean
and you know got has a corvette or
whatever it is right
yeah he has a nice car i roast
you have roast no that's his license
plate oh
but so we're gonna be like that you just
have to take it one step at a time you
know like start lotioning yeah
start uh actually you know working on
your craft
and not your looks are you trying to say
that tony didn't work on his craft no
i'm saying you
whoa no i'm saying that's not important
that's
that's like don't call me don't
focus on that just focus on better at
comedy
[ __ ] i'm gonna focus on everything
because i am all
omnipotent what is that
powerful a beautiful person you are
pretty well you don't have to limit
yourself you don't have to be like
no my [ __ ] is just going to be stink
because i'm working on my
comedy um you know
so you think that you want to be
successful
you're going to look good minimum of
effort into your ass no i put a lot of
effort
i want to get a bidet i put a lot of
effort
in putting other people's [ __ ] in my
ass
but this girl she would go do i look fat
in this
and i would have to say no right
but it was like my real answer oh my
real answer was like uh
dude you're getting fat
you know
i know but at the time dude it didn't
feel like i could be honest
i don't know you know honest
i mean you can always be honest to
friends
yeah i think um yes but
yes okay you're a little fat right now
you have a big old fatty yeah
actually did gain some weight over the
past few days yeah
it's true i noticed you it's very
noticeable like just a few pounds
so okay i actually i actually was
observing how skinny you
look and sickly you're actually i was
much skinnier last time you guys saw me
in a sexual way
pretty skinny i never really noticed
that we all think you're beautiful
and i was just kidding about the fatty
thing i was just saying that but you can
actually be really honest with me i
noticed that you're nicer to me
in a certain way where there's like
probably a huge
dig that you have on me that you don't
share
like this other guy oh yo remember when
you said that to that one guy that he
looked like he was turning into a tree
yeah my mind exploded
because that's what i was like trying to
figure out for a few days
i was like this guy it's like a that
that feeling like that
bad trip feeling of like ah what is he
what he's gonna crawl into the couch and
he's not actually turning into a tree
i don't know i mean like at what point
is it basically what's going on
his body is just a bunch of follicles
hair follicles and
veins we would have a common ancestor
with trees
yeah if you tripped hard enough you
would see everything i i don't even know
you're talking about but that's a good
rose arrow
when you set because i was thinking
about it for such a long time
and then you said it and i was like god
you always you always get to the
accurate
point and it can be really hurtful to
people because they're like trying to
hide it
or something you know or they don't
notice it themselves i didn't think of
it
until it happened i wasn't like he's a
tree he's a tree i did think of that
with your camo bikini
though okay yeah that roast
yeah that was well worded you know
i was thinking about how to word it that
one i planned yeah that's a good idea
so what you did is you're like camo
bikini camouflage
what is she camouflaging oh her breasts
is that that weird
and um wait why would she need to
camouflage them because they're the
roast is that they're small
yeah you don't need to camouflage your
breasts
you don't need camouflage to hide your
tits yeah and then you change it to a
boston accent
and you go you don't need camouflage to
hide your tits is that a boston
or whatever yeah yeah it's crazy sugar
plums
how do you like them apples huh
sugar plums sugar what is a sugar plum
i think it's like a christmas treat it
sounds delicious
i know but it's really good when
somebody says something that's like
well worded and then you can unpack it
you can see how they actually got to it
so hopefully you can start learning how
to do it yourself
what do you um i do know how to do it
what are you talking about
riley is naturally talented and that's
why he's so tortured
and never goes to mike's i've
cower and fear yeah
because it makes you feel so much better
than everyone else that you get scared
of your own
perfection it's pale whiteness
maybe yeah oh pale pain his paleness
is here lord like for instance when you
did your joke about uh can i should i be
doing this just like saying all your
jokes and
undressing them should i do this okay
when you're like um
i'm from south korea yep a real
southerner i love
guns and uh fighting communism
which is so great because it really the
communism part is so great because
you're like oh
it's true politically you know
yeah come back line where i was like i
hate communists more than you do sir
they killed my grandmother
and it was amazing that alex jones was
right there and he's like
yeah yeah they do both hate communism
like
i was like oh but you can come together
that's such a perfect you and i that's
such a perfect moment in that joke
i like how he laughed at the black
panther joke
yeah that's a good joke what are you
gonna say he's a liberal
i unpacked that joke because i got
intimidated because i was like [ __ ]
that's like so good
let me see if i can get how to see if i
could make it myself or whatever like
take the steps i'm ecuadorian i'm from
south america
yeah yeah i could literally have done
the same thing but so you said
i'm south korean and you're like
southerner
you know it's so easy to like retake the
steps and then you're like okay at least
i know how you did it yeah
it's like that's how you get good at
cooking right you like figure out what
recipes actually are and then
after a while you can do it yourself
sorry i know that you're so good at this
uh
all right why aren't you on the dead
squad or whatever the dead show
the dead they'll be dead soon enough
dead poets society
and that is a threat by the way what
oh uh
well good stuff i gotta put in my time
so what do you think about the goddamn
austin comedy scene we got to kill tony
here we got joe rogan opening up his new
club we got adam egan telling me good
job after every set
big deal who knows but also we also got
the creek in the cave so what do you
guys think about all four of those
issues mainly the atomy good thing
who is that he's the booker at the
comedy store
and also this new club called joe
rogan's new [ __ ] club
that's what it's called really yeah
i don't know that would be so funny yeah
and neon lights
yeah it's just like so thrown together
like it's just like at a bar
like yeah what if it what if it sucks
because i trust that it's not gonna suck
but what if he was like
everyone's just like oh the tv is always
playing
it's like the party and there's just
like the table's sticky there's just
yeah that would be the ultimate downfall
because it would be like it's like
like everyone's like drinking loud stars
they're like oh joe rogan cool we love
the club
again you guys like it this is [ __ ]
awesome right yeah
bingo yeah uh this is so cool
[Laughter]
hey these are coming guys
um i i just had my comedians come but
they haven't been coming yikes
um it's going to be fine though it'll be
really cool obviously it's going to be
the best club
he has the best money in the world yeah
he has good taste
um yeah his podcast studio looks really
nice
i actually feel good about it here
at first when i came here there was less
mics
right yeah there's like much many many
more mics
and like good people good vibes
more good people because at first i was
like yo i got burnt out after three days
of being here
because i was surrounded by like some
weird open mic and i was like [ __ ] what
us
leo um but it's okay just kidding yeah
i think it's getting worse that's
because your attitude has been getting
worse so
for the best i'm getting about what you
were like i don't want to do it anymore
i just want to like uh he needed to
figure out his life
and pay his rent it's okay to take a
break
from you know get a new girlfriend
yeah yeah you're one of those people
one of what people are kind of people
trying to be happy
yeah you want to be tied down to
something no i don't
i want to be balanced in my life dude do
you think manipulating a girl
and making her get all emotional with
you every all day
every day is going to like be good for
you
that's why you think relationships are
manipulating people
all the constant manipulation
why do you think i manipulate people
well
okay i guess i don't know that
well do we manipulate you to come to
this podcast
no are you manipulating us i ask who's
the manipulator in this relationship i
don't um
a like a relationship with a girl is
much more like you guys have to talk a
lot and there's going to be all these
like
expectations and you're going to every
single day you're going to be like well
i'm going to the mics
and she's going to be like what why not
why are you going to the mics
i'm not saying i want that per se i just
want to be more balanced
i want to like do other things and like
meet other people but
yeah yeah i mean yeah like why not like
i mean obviously i'm not gonna like
be the girl who doesn't understand my
values that's why you can be with the
band people
that want us to party every single night
with them and they have girls
around them uh i don't want to party per
se either
um they talk riley wants the perfect
life of simple rick
i want to so do you think she's just
gonna be laying in here or something
like and then you you leave
yeah that's it you come back and she's
still laying there yeah and
she's like oh i've been sleeping i've
been waiting yeah i'm like go back to
sleep
i'm playing katan yeah we're playing
guitar now
she's like okay let me know when you
went outside
yeah i'm just a whole what happened to
the last girl is it not a possibility
anymore
gossip why would you say that
with two i think you i just thought that
maybe you were with somebody in austin
so far
at least like a few people in austin so
far and i just figured riley [ __ ]
are they still possibilities i think
it's laid i
i'm i don't know okay riley
so what are you gonna are you on an app
or you're are you gonna
come you can look on tinder
right yeah is that fun
it's okay we're freaking him out sorry
um
yeah this is it's good you know well i'm
yeah
i mean yeah
maybe you could establish a casual
relationship with someone so you're like
hey i just want to like have somebody to
[ __ ] and hang out with do you want that
yeah that could be really nice i bet a
lot of people are actually looking for
that now
yeah i have a feeling they are yeah
millennials you know yeah i mean that's
what
yeah that's basically like what dating
is now it's just kind of [ __ ] and
hanging out
really yeah uh
[Music]
what i shouldn't have made fun of this
guy
are you on a drug what so this guy was
wearing a shirt and i kept reading his
shirt
oh i just i don't know
i don't know was it a comedian yeah
they can be very sensitive people i know
yeah but um yeah you were talking about
like
do you guys need more weed or something
both of your vibes went down
i'm sorry if i just got too real you're
asking
him about his relationships my most
sensitive topic
well i'm like you're a dick you're in
the age
dude before you hit 24 you're like
really
like actively trying to like get a
figure out who you are
yeah when you're 22 it's true you're
like you're like really trying to find
somebody to like
marry like you're like really hardcore
depends on the person you're 25 26
you're like wait a minute
i feel like riley's more on the stage of
who am i
i know so much but i don't blame you
anymore you're gonna need
a lot of it's gonna be a tough
ride for the next two years for you
romantically you're gonna
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] well i mean it
can't get much worse
no i'm sure yeah just don't you know tie
you know just don't
put any emotions into it because that'll
get you hurt
yeah well good advice
just go tell people that you want to
have fun in your
early 20s and maybe they'll say the same
thing
hi i'm in my early 20s and i just want
to have fun what is this linkedin
yeah basically what linkedin is
yeah yeah in your early 20s you really
um
try to tie a serious relationship into
your work
well are you just talking about yourself
or everybody and i read a book about
adult crises and
that's like uh 18 through 23 it's like
this crazy time where
a lot of people end up getting married
and [ __ ] and that's not a good idea
yeah well it was for our parents
generation but we live in different
times well it's like a genetic like
you genetically like want to sing
and and stuff you want the one that i
want do you feel a baby feeling
sometimes like
no i i still have not felt that baby in
here oh there's a hole where a baby is
supposed to be
why isn't there a baby in here right now
that would be i'm glad that i don't have
that feeling
that would be tough uh
to really want a baby what what do you
think riley's real issue is
not that he wants to be in a
relationship and marry but like
i think he wants well the everything the
real issue is that he's 22.
yeah but my like thing is something
what we have is that we're like uh
my career like my career my uh
aspirations
satisfy me enough
i'm not gonna talk to free i'm not gonna
speak for you but it's like your
aspirations satisfy you enough so you
could have the pick of the litter
in terms of male sex and you choose
but are you poverty instead are you gay
no
tell me why you think a pic of the
litter is a good thing
you could have maybe think about if you
could have a pick up would you have one
option to choose if you can do it right
who do you think is a good uh penis
for me is that a nobody thank you lucas
hurl
um lucas earl oh [ __ ] he's a beautiful
guy
right a day he's a beautiful day and i
guess lucas oh lucas mccrary
oh [ __ ] i don't know who look at her but
lucas mac
rob rob the guy that bartends at the
creek
um fahey manoir
i don't like him like that alex jones
yeah who do you think would be a good
wife for me
hans kim i only know like a few
comedians here in austin
and i'm not supposed to talk about them
anymore because we have to take a break
like like famous comedians like eliza
schlesinger
ellie wong
why she's so mean she's so like dark
and [ __ ] um
roseanne burr a lesbian
yeah you're not going to find one
swedish
uh i would go for i would go for there's
probably like funny normal
there's a lot of normal people who are
actually funny but they're just like
successful and they don't need to be in
the deep depths like my dad
why why would you sigh of that i don't
know your dad
bringing back her anger i don't know
your dad uh
but that's what i noticed you know i
dated a jew in new york
who do you think riley would date
probably sarah silverman
yes definitely probably
esther kavitsky you know esther pavitz
yeah
you guys could just be sensitive
together like just like your sex is just
like worms
no she can't be sillier than i
am i don't know maybe she can she's
really silly though
i don't like silly on silly i don't know
her
so yeah well she's a silly
about goose cummings i think she would
break you
yeah yeah she's too serious she needs
somebody that's very strong
she's a lesbian no she's not
you can't just say [ __ ] like that yeah
i was joking i'm sorry lady
lady um who
i feel like you would do well with
a very sweet girl donna yeah
you dude i won't i don't want to talk
[ __ ] and everything and like
mess around with people but like
somebody like holly
very sweet little girl not and i don't
mean little in a bad way
like somebody you're she's funny so
she's not like ah
you know but she's a sweet little girl
and you're yeah so you can be a man
yeah compared to him in a cuddle and
she's like okay you know and i'm not
saying hollywood those are good
you guys could be and then y'all will
giggle
this could be like a couple in the
suburbs and you guys both like respect
each other
it's not holly and specifically like no
one wants to sleep in separate beds yeah
you never [ __ ] her you never really [ __ ]
her
she's just dying maybe we shouldn't talk
about people like this that's why
i'm saying it's not her specifically i'm
just saying that that's what i'm trying
like when i have a woman for you that's
my visual it's like a
very nice sweet gentle girl who has a
sensation
i like someone who's creative and we'll
put and we'll push me
yeah she doesn't and that's another good
thing about holly she'll push you
why even though because she's smarter
holly oh no
no i think she's a boy christy brought
her up
she's my she matches the vision that i
have that's all but it's okay
if you had to have anyone's career right
now who would it be joe rogan
you want to crystal yeah i would have
yeah i would have andrew schultz would
have a good career
um theo vaughn
let's just talk about people who we want
to be um
i want to be christy vera so that i can
probably
give you glitter and [ __ ] i want to make
the right decisions and dominate life
so if you were me would you go [ __ ]
the bartender at the creek
is that is that a right decision yes
what the [ __ ]
because life is you're not going to make
the right decisions dude there's
right decision there's stds yeah
there's like uh you know all the things
that go into play
like when you have sex with somebody
that's what she thinks about people
i know when you bring a girl want
everything to be clean
when you bring a girl into she wants sex
to be like surgery
yeah when you bring a girl into the van
how long do you have to like deal with
all the other consequences
like cleaning the sheets so i'm not
talking about any girl
specific but like one of the girls that
you recently brought into your van like
um you have no idea where we [ __ ]
wait uh yeah it was her house right
recently so but anyways you're talking
about but go ahead
um it doesn't have to be any one in
specific right
just one of the recent ones was it
completely
amazing or were there parts that you're
like oh god like
god yes there were parts that
were annoying but so but that's life
like everything
everything bring somebody into comedy
yeah
okay there's negative consequences to
[ __ ] the bartender at the creek
yeah you never know what they're gonna
smell
like and just all kinds of things but
that's also in the positive direction
you never know what they're gonna bring
to your life
that you're not focusing on because you
have risk aversion
because you were hurt in the past or
something you just don't want us
you just don't want a sweaty hairy dick
in your mouth
that's hard to say like you just don't
think you
i mean i would pick like someone because
like sex
yeah you don't have to give blow jobs if
you don't like it you can do a lot of
other things with your
hand fingers and you have to talk to
them um
sometimes that can be really bad like
but haven't you been in a good
relationship
um yes
and you're just repressing good
relationships i've been in relationships
where there were good moments
oh that's why was that sad to me
like just like a moment where you're
like oh this is a good moment and then
the res
the rest is like annoying again yeah
yeah but
i believe the same thing that's that's
true that's what you choose to focus on
there's good and bad in a relationship
but you just hate people but
i mean we're we're like he's like a
child when it comes to this topic he's
like a
child and we're like really
he just doesn't say anything like a big
thing for him right now
yeah like love we're really like dude no
yeah i mean we're more jaded we're like
telling you that santa isn't real
well i'm trying to figure out the same
thing as you guys like we're all
obviously trying to figure this out you
guys haven't figured it out either
i yes and that's why you don't respect
us but uh i don't respect
you because you haven't figured anything
out you haven't even tried
you're just starting out me yeah
i've done i've done a lot of stuff you
like tyler the creator
so you're like excited about his new
album and stuff
yeah well i like music yeah you figured
that out
why are you i'm not an idiot okay i
haven't
like i've done i've done a lot of stuff
like
the mouth of babes comes wisdom no
i'm i'm joking yeah i mean he's like
has a healthier outlook on dating yeah
because
he's not like hateful like we i like
going on dates and
being like hey we're on a date but
that's so sweet once people reach the
age of like 18 or 19 like they're pretty
much adults and there's like no
difference in
age besides like cosmetics
when there's like an adult like it's
like uh it's age it doesn't really
matter dude i recently was like
basically dating a guy who
i didn't notice and then suddenly out he
said something that was
so naive about the world and i was like
how old are you
and he said 21. is he like mad oh okay
okay that's fine all right we have two
good jobs
guys signing off for hans kim
hans kim i mean riley yes uh
thanks uh so christy did you have
anything else you wanted to say
about dating um
it was always a big difference because
all right thank you everyone
[Laughter]
i do i should have known you yeah
what did you want to say they're very
[ __ ] naive and like
he would call me you know talk on the
phone
he would talk on the phone with me and
like say [ __ ] that he discovered
he'd be like did you know that like
something about racism you know did you
and i'd be like dude
shut the [ __ ] up like he'd always have
these discoveries and [ __ ]
yeah cause you already knew it and be
like lecturing me about
naive new ideas that he was just
learning
and i'd be like oh my god i hate that i
hate shut up
this is a waste of time yeah oh my god
you didn't want to talk about it
but he was like just discovering it
because he's young yeah and so i felt
bad to be mean i was like
dude it's just because you're young like
i'm so sorry but i can't i can't
hear this like it's it's i have other
things to do like
but maybe don't bring up his age when
telling him to shut up
because well that's the only reason it's
not that it's like you know any that's
the only reason is that
you just learned this and there's all
these other levels
and i don't want to hear you lecturing
like that is like a bad way
to tell someone that you don't want to
talk right now
like if you want to say that it's really
bad there's a better way to say i didn't
know what to do i've never experienced
that before and i was like oh my god
i've never experienced it well then use
your age and experience
for something more than shutting down
conversation and i didn't want to have
the conversation like i was like i'm
busy i'm busy like
i don't want to it's weird that you
would have walls where you don't want to
talk about things
dude if i was like lecturing if i was a
20 year old you talk about everything
huh should we talk about everything um
there's just a moment sometimes when
you're like this person isn't work this
brain
isn't worth it it's not making it's not
gonna grow my brain
and i'm not gonna help like i don't
wanna sit here and teach
that's why women always say they don't
want to date younger guys because they
don't want to teach them and i was like
this is it
like that's what it is but teaching is a
great i want to be like
a pl abc and he's like
yeah it's like i just learned the
alphabet abcd you're like oh my god
but guys think it's cute no we're nicer
than
women and no i think it's because you
think oh you're like a kid you're like a
baby
you're like a child let me [ __ ] you and
we're like well it's because we're
stronger than you
today i'm in fourth grade we know how to
get to where we're going
is it is it off
let's goodbye bye thank you